[Music]
welcome to quad Riga the European Union
is heading into a decisive week as its
parliament prepares to vote on the most
important posts in Brussels breaking
with decades of male dominance heads of
key EU member states have nominated two
women for top positions with current
German defence minister Ursula Fonda
Lyon as president of the Commission and
IMF chief Christine Lagarde as future
president of the European Central Bank
but critics say those choices reflect
back room power politics and they're
threatening to torpedo the nominations
with the EU facing pressing challenges
strong leadership is more important than
ever will it emerge from a process with
democratic deficits EU top jobs haggling
instead of inspiration that's our topic
and here are our guests it's a pleasure
to welcome a menu ASEAN's she is a
freelance journalist originally from
France who works with us here at
Deutsche Welle as well as for French
print and broadcast media
she says the scramble for the EU stop
jobs further highlights discrepancies
between the Member States and damages
the Union Malan niche works for an as an
element analyst for the German Council
on Foreign Relations
he says the visit broad group of Eastern
European countries has maneuvered itself
into a corner their lack of
representation in top EU jobs is a
significant problem for EU cohesion it
will come back to haunt the region and
it's a pleasure to welcome Tom Nuttall
he is the Berlin correspondent for the
British weekly The Economist he thinks
it was an old-fashioned franco-german
backroom stitch up with all the top jobs
going to old Europe but it also
highlighted a subtle shift in power away
from Angela Merkel and toward Emmanuelle
macaw so Tom let's start with that
backroom stitch up as you call it
actually there were official candidates
for these positions there were rallies
there were election posters there were
TV debates
Orsola formed
who is now nominated for the presidency
of the Commission was not in any of
those so what's going on here but funny
isn't it I mean Ursula von der Leyen has
been on a charm offensive in the
European Parliament recently trying to
convince all of the political groupings
there that they ought to vote for her to
confirm her for the position of the
European Commission and of course
they're grilling her on all sorts of
things from climate change to defense to
economic policy and she has to invent a
program almost out of thin air because
as you say she was not a named candidate
before the election what happened was
there is this idea so-called Spitz in
candidate and lead candidates each of
those political groupings proposed a
candidate for the President of the
Commission before the elections the idea
being that voters would have an idea of
who they wanted to see as president of
the European Commission the problem is
it is leaders the heads of government in
the European Union who nominate the
president of the Commission and not very
many of them like the idea of handing
power to the European Parliament in that
way and so when they met to name their
nominee a couple of weeks ago the
various candidates that have been
proposed as part of this system one by
one were rejected and they ended up with
as I say this franco-german stitch-up
and Ursula von der Leyen currently the
defense minister here in Germany
proposed as president of the Commission
thank you very much that was a very
concise explanation Milan certainly
Geographic blocks were a big part of
this backroom power deal Eastern
European leaders did all they could to
torpedo one of the lead candidates why
first of all be sure grad group
comprising Poland Hungary Czech Republic
Slovakia is not all Eastern Europe or
new member states but they are the ones
that are that organized themselves and
they didn't like proposed candidate who
was pitting candidate of the socialist
group France Timmerman's because they
told he's too divisive
now the position of the Vichy grad group
was shaped especially by Poland and
Hungary which are the two countries that
are under the art so-called article 7
sanctioned procedure for breaching rule
of law and basic values of the EU in the
outgoing European Commission France
Timmerman's as a first vice Prez
than was in charge of this procedure the
very spritzen candidate for the SPD it
was the one who had made trouble for
these exactly so in the first reading
this was a payback time
at the same time I think there was a
deeper political message behind this
these two countries Poland Hungary and
their nationalist conservative
governments want one thing from Brussels
first to be left alone or they are
pushing a different vision of the EU
then is proposed by many mainstream
parties at the U level these political
groupings and that is namely than the
Europe of the nations so nation-states
should be a building blocks and European
institutions including the next
Commission should leave us alone to do
our own thing therefore France
timmermans also if you look at their
interest was too much to swallow and I
think also he was too divisive candidate
in east-west relations also for the
other Eastern European countries and
just explain to me very briefly because
your opening statement said that the
visa card group had maneuvered
themselves into a corner but in fact
haven't they demonstrated how much power
they can wield in the first round they
were proudly boasting that they blocked
France thermos I think it was more
complicated in fact they took the blame
or they claim the this this blocking
power but in fact France timmermans
was shut down also at the main political
grouping European People's Party by
rebellion of other Prime Minister's
including Prime Minister of Thailand and
others who couldn't swallow proposed the
deal by Angela Merkel German Chancellor
saying that we should give the position
to second largest part a second largest
political grouping to socialist and they
were saying this is this is the biggest
prize in Brussels it should go to us as
the party that won the elections and
then the Vichy grad group the Eastern
European leaders for their own domestic
audience he said oh we are also against
it it was clear there was no majority or
that they had a blocking power together
with Italy so was much more complicating
just them but they will be blamed this
remember and I think it's not clear what
they got in the returned in the second
round so now one understands better in
manual why you call this a scramble you
said in your opening statement it will
damage the Union why well it's a very
damaging because if you look at it
people actually voted for parties with
like I said people on posters were
advertised to them like we are the
candidates like I am for example Manfred
Weber was selling himself after Spitz
and candidate for the EPP group so not
European People's Party conservative
party actually so logically he should
have been nominated as the member of the
group which has gotten the most votes in
those elections he should have been
nominated and know what happened it's
back to politics where leaders decided
between themselves who they wanted or
not wanted as as European Commission
President and that is not the will of
the people so there is a huge disk
discrepancy between what was advertised
on paper what people voted for I mean
those who had enough interest to go
voting and what is happening right now
which is the same old fashioned politics
between leaders and mostly between
French France and Germany we have to say
that it's actually the same politics
that people don't believe in anymore Tom
does the fact that the deal was put
together by heads of state member
countries show us that in the end the
Commission and the Parliament are
essentially paper tigers I wouldn't go
that far in fact I think you can look at
it another way and I think one reason
why this matters so much the heads of
state is because the European Commission
in certain respects is a rather powerful
body European Parliament has accrued
more and more powers ever since it
became an independently elected body in
1979 that said it is clear that a lot of
the leaders want to keep the Commission
on a fairly tight leash one of the
things that emerge it hasn't been
discussed so much since this big summit
a couple of weeks ago is it not only was
von der Leyen herself chosen by the
leaders but as part of the overall
package which I think we're going to go
on to discuss
not only were other top jobs discussed
but some of the second-tier jobs were
discussed and in particular vice
presidents of the European Commission
the leaders decided among themselves
that a couple of named including France
timmermans who we were discussing before
will be vice presidents of the
Commission that's a that is a that is a
decision that is supposed to be in the
gift of the president to choose their
own vice presidents in fact that the
Heads of Government were choosing
themselves tells you quite a lot about
how important it is for them to retain
control over the process so given the
democratic deficits that you've all
identified would you if you were a
member of the European Parliament next
Tuesday when the vote comes up would you
vote Ursula fond de Lyon in or out
would you essentially punish the the
leaders for doing this backroom deal yes
or no vote in or out yes because I don't
believe in specifically that process in
the first place I think it is
essentially a power a backroom deal just
in the different institutions in the
European Parliament I would vote yes
simply because what is the plan B what's
the other candidate and how do we
renegotiate and like this job or do we
have to reopen the whole package the
whole package has already been decided
so in order to exit a deadlock I would
vote yes
time sorry to be born but I would vote
yes as well and third the reasons that
both Melania and Emmanuel gave I also
don't agree with the bits and candy
dustman system although I wouldn't vote
yes to stick it to them
I think the Ursula von der Leyen is is
certainly a better candidate the Manfred
Weber would have been but it is also
true that if there are if she's to be
rejected in the European Parliament that
would create an unprecedented
constitutional crisis within the EU
between its institutions and I don't
think anybody wants that so next Tuesday
we'll know whether your opinions were
reflective of the way that Emmie peas
think let us now take a closer look at
ursula fond de lyon and christine
lagarde assuming the Parliament does
approve them the EU stop post will
include more women than ever before
as she enters the race to become the
president of the European Commission
Ursula Fund the lion is under political
fire the German ministers defense leaves
behind an army that's in a purse state
the qualified medical doctors image as a
feisty reformer has taken a knock but
her supporters point out that the mother
of seven is a staunch European who's
known Brussels since her childhood has a
good Network and is fluent in French in
English as well as German Christine
Lagarde is the grand dame of French
politics the 63 year old economist has
run the International Monetary Fund for
eight years
monitor izing it without causing a fuss
but also not shying away from
criticizing US president Donald Trump
first trade policies Lagarde is
considered a supporter of redistribution
within the euro zone at expense of
richer States and an opponent of tough
austerity policies while women's power
drive Europe forward
M'Lynn earth laFonda lion has been in
Brussels the last few days courting
Europe the members of the European
Parliament how'd she do I'm not in
Brussels I don't know but I think she is
doing a stone suggested she is building
a program from thin air very fast she
has a team behind her she needs to be
like consensus to to be confirmed next
week interestingly enough she does have
the backing of some of those Eastern
European leaders we've been talking
about and also of the populist leader in
Italy what does that tell us she's more
known and more positively known
politician in centuries in Europe than
many others as a Minister of Defense
she tried to forge a common line between
the EON NATO and basically I think
position on Germany in central Eastern
Europe is more balanced than it was
before I mean they'd rather accept a
German many of these leaders rather
accept a German conservative candidate
at the top job at the European
Commission than a socialist Dutch person
because there was a perception that even
10 years 15 years after 15 years after
the Year lodgement some countries
regardless of they do at home are
treated as a second class or as barely
admitted and I'll accept it and on many
divisive issues and there are many in
the EU they want their opinion to be
included into policymaking and they
there is a feeling not only on behalf of
these controversial governments in
Poland Hungary that have problem with
rule of law but by others that ultra fun
Leiden will include their view their
views and interests and preferences more
than for instance France timmermans
would Tom you said in your opening
statement that that there's a
discrepancy between different countries
that's reflected in this deal
interestingly enough our report
reflected a discrepancy in the way that
a fund a lion is perceived here in
Germany as
to abroad so maybe you can say a word
about why that is and what your take on
her qualifications is whether you think
she would be a good candidate to lead
the Commission so there's an irony in
that when the European Council the the
the collection of heads of state and
government voted on this the one leader
who didn't vote in support of Ursula von
der Leyen was Angela Merkel she
abstained and there's a reason for that
which is that coalition partner the SPD
the Social Democrats reject the idea of
under Lana's Commission president and in
Germany when the coalition partners
disagree then in European discussions
the relative relevant minister or in
this case Chancellor has to abstain the
SPD are taking a very very tough line on
this I mean of course Herstal von der
Leyen comes from a different party they
also consider that they're upset that
the spits and candid arkin system was
jettisoned in this instance but I think
there's more to it than that this is
about German domestic coalition politics
this is an extremely awkward coupling
now between the CDU in the SPD the SPD
who are currently leaderless very very
unpopular in the polls they need to take
every opportunity that they have to show
that they can stand against the CDU to
demonstrate to their supporters that
they still have an independent spirit
and I think that is what this is about
so leaving that domestic Tiff's aside
what do you think about funder Lyon
would she be a good president for the
Commission I I think the jury is out in
some respects I think she will be good
she has a good Network
she is well respected across Europe as
well as in America she has strong
experience in some of the areas that are
going to count for the in the next five
years most obviously defense you've been
in the defense ministry in Germany for
some time but I think there are plenty
of reasons to worry she does she unlike
almost every previous Commission
President she has not been a head of
state or a government of course she
doesn't have any particular experience
in economic policy and that could be a
big issue for the next Commission
president and what she used to be
considered as a possible successor to
Angler Merkel some years ago that notion
has disappeared now and I think it's
largely because Ursula von der Leyen was
not able to build a support base for
herself in
the Christian Democratic Union and when
you're President of the European
Commission where you're constrained by
different opinions by different
governments all the time it's very
important to be able to build alliances
and I think the question of whether she
is able to do that remains very open
Amanda well while Ursula Fonda lion has
been generating some mixed reviews
there's been a lot of positive buzz
around the nomination of Christine
Lagarde would you say that this
represents this deal that was done does
this represent a shift in the balance of
power away from Germany and toward
France I think both women can definitely
bring in the game-changing approach to
to to Brussels is it really idea but
then advantage of France now like okay
Angela Merkel abstained from voting but
she actually nominated also da von der
Leyen
in her government since 2005 this is one
of her closest allies Angela Merkel is
like on her last mandate as a German
Chancellor and with the health issues
she's currently experiencing we don't
know how much longer she will be around
and she just placed probably her closest
ally as president of the EU Commission
so Emmanuel macron didn't want man Scott
Weber and he got his way with the
nomination of also laFonda Lyon but I
don't think France is taking any
advantage on the Germans they would also
be the first time since the 60s that
Germany would have European Commission
President so I think it's a winning
situation for both of those countries
and perhaps detrimental to any other
country in Europe let me briefly ask you
Tom to comment on where you think
Christine Lagarde might take European
monetary policy and where you whether
you see a shift of direction they're
away from German austerity and toward
more burden sharing between the rich
north and the indebted southern European
countries that's certainly something
that France has passed pushed for in the
past are we likely to see Lagarde go in
that direction you don't know she is not
an economist she has no experience in a
central bank which is why for some
people this was certainly unexpected
nomination perhaps an unusual one what
we do know is that she has been largely
supportive
the fairly accommodative monetary policy
pursued by the current ECB president
mario draghi I think the question is
going to be to what extent she is able
to use the bully pulpit of this job to
be able to encourage countries
particularly Germany to be a little bit
more a little bit less fiscally
restrictive now of course it's not up to
the president of the European Central
Bank to determine how government's spend
their money but Mario Draghi regularly
beat the drum for countries that had
what he called fiscal space like Germany
which has a big surplus to spend more
Christine Lagarde I think from what we
can tell during her time at the helm of
the IMF is largely going to be
supportive of that she moved the IMF
away from its its previous position on
on fiscal policy so I think we would
probably see continuity there the
question is how successful will she be
in deploying her political abilities
rather than her economic or technical
ones to be able to convince those
governments to do more I think there
might be an interesting agenda on her
behalf and that is contributing to
building up a eurozone as an
institutional way and building up euro
as a currency of strengthening that if
that takes place within the next five
years which is her Monday's I think then
it would also create more
differentiation within for instance
Eastern Europe between the eurozone
member states mostly small countries the
Baltics Slovakia Slovenia and the rest
of Eastern Europe which is less
integrated economically and financially
we do and this is where I think French
president macro wants to move the EU and
Germany was so that they are I am not
sure whether Eastern Europeans by you
know celebrating this package whether
they know were they what they will get
I'm gonna stop you right there because I
want to bring in a very brief report to
look at the pressing challenges that in
fact Europe is facing it's very clear
that we need strong leadership in Europe
as the EU moves forward to to deal with
challenges that actually demand
multilateral solutions
the first test will be brexit britain is
currently set to leave the European
Union at the end of October the new
Prime Minister whether Boris Johnson or
Jeremy Hunt will call on Brussels to
renegotiate the question is how Britain
and the other 27 states of the EU come
to terms both socially and economically
after brexit the trade dispute with the
US and China it's very possible that US
President Donald Trump will carry out
his threat to impose tariffs on European
goods this would do considerable damage
to the EU economy migration from Africa
and the Middle East even though there's
a common EU Asylum system Italy in
certain Eastern European states refused
to take in asylum seekers the European
Union is threatened from within by the
rise of right-wing populism in many
member states
is the EU prepared for so many
challenges
okay briefly one-word answer what do you
eat see as the biggest challenge facing
the EU they money whale migration
definitely come and the question of
European sovereignty and how its
maintained in an increasingly
antagonistic relationship between the US
and China for me it's EU unity and
cohesion how it how the EU system will
be able to work under this very
fragmented political arrangements in
Brussels okay so that one takes us to
some degree toward the brexit question
and the question again of many countries
and right-wing populist looking toward
more nation-state power rather than less
what do you think could a north of the
funder Lyon perhaps supported by
Christine Lagarde a central bank
governor face that challenge of rising
nationalism and of pushback against
multilateralism well that challenge
comes from outside externally from to
you and internally there is a less
capacity to agree on some issues in
foreign policy like sanctions on China
because Chinese are very active
internally and they are buying countries
that where they invested Greece is one
example they are trying to reference
they worked or Hungary for that matter
and Germany proposed an idea of shift in
the EU foreign policy mechanism to a
qualified majority vote which is a no-go
for many countries I think this is a big
challenge for the new high
representative for foreign policy
Spanish Foreign Minister which was a
portal and the basic problem is that the
EU system was built to pacify you
problems and challenges internally
rather than to represent Europe and
externally on the global on the global
level and this is where the challenges
will come in many ways you mentioned
migration there has been a lot of
pushback exactly from the Eastern
European countries on that would you say
that a north of fun dare Lyon can bring
a multilateral workable
Ellucian forward briefly she doesn't say
she definitely has the the stator to to
lead that fight it's actually a fight
where we're witnessing we cannot close
borders where there are no borders there
are geographical places where migrants
are actually dying at sea those migrants
are actually human beings there are
still sinking we have to find a solution
Europe wasn't built on the values of
closing doors to people in distress and
she has to address that I think she has
the means to do so and Tom finally yeah
that Tech Cold War US versus China can
these women and the others who've been
nominated can they really ensure a place
for Europe at the table so you don't
code you incur the current President of
the European Commission actually it
turned out handled Donald Trump rather
well and the European Commission has an
awful lot of clout when it comes to
trade it is legally mandated to
negotiate on behalf the Member States I
think is very much an open question
whether von der Leyen will do the same
thing it's possible that her past as
German defense minister might come to
howtechs there's nothing that Donald
Trump likes better than bashing German
defense policy
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us and thanks to you out
there for being with us as well we do go
into our summer break now but we look
forward to seeing you back here with
quad Riga when we start up again at the
end of the summer see you then
[Music]